- This place is fancy.
Ooh, they even got
welcome meatballs.
- And by the looks of things,
I'm easily the hardest dude
in this camp.
What's up, Elbows?
We 'bout to dominate
this bitch.
- Welcome to the ML Carr Jr. III
Elite Basketball Camp
for Future Stars.
Give yourselves a hand
for being invited.
[applause]
- It's obvious this place is
only for well-trained athletes.
- And Grover said we suck.
- I'ma suck
on more of these balls.
- I'm finna serve these fools
with a cherry on top.
You ready, J?
- Shit, ready for lunch.
They got a carve-your-own-
prime-rib station.
- Why the hoops ain't down?
And where them balls at?
- And now introducing
former NBA World Champion,
the legend, the best benchwarmer
the league has ever known,
the great Jack Haley...
hologram.
- Yeah, well, all right, dude!
Let's get hype!
Welcome, brethren.
Here you're gonna learn from
the greats of the ole pine.
Playing time is for posers.
We can't all be starters,
and with our help,
none of you will be.
But at this
benchwarmers' camp--
- Benchwarmer camp?
- I thought we were elite.
- Behind every Hall of Famer,
there's a benchwarmer
yelling his heart out.
Enjoy the camp, gents.
And remember our motto:
No shots, no stress,
no shine, no sweat!
Say it with me!
all: No shots, no stress,
no shine, no sweat!
No shots, no stress,
- Fuck you mean,
no shine?
- No shine?